carlos rodon will be
the starter for game two he's the
northern ohio hyundai
starting pitcher for chicago he made
seven starts last year and then had
tommy john surgery one of those starts
came against the indians where he went
six innings here in cleveland gave up
two hits in just
one run and struck out nine he did get
the win but
this guy has good stuff he's always
pitch well against the indians but he's
had
his injury problems and surgeries over
his career jose ramirez
hits this one down the left field line
that's going to stay fair and it'll go
into the corner
and ramirez lost his hat he'll stroll
into second base with a one-out double
it was an off-speed pitch you can see he
was out front but he was able to keep it
fair
get it down into the corner so jose will
have a double runner and scoring
position here in the first
and up comes francisco lindor
and there's a fastball he turns that one
around deep left field it's over the
head of del monaco
coming around third jose ramirez will
score linder has to hurry
and frankie does beat the tag it's an
rbi double in the indians lead one to
nothing
he gives the indians the lead in the
nightcap with a first inning
rbi double to left one down for carlos
santana
the pitch swung on and blasted to left
forget about it carlos santana to the
bleachers and left
and the indians have a three-nothing
lead
and the indians doing something they've
never done before against rodon
and that's light them up carlos santana
with a laser
shot to the bleachers and left his first
home run
and his first rbi's of the campaign
so the indians jumping on road down
before he can get comfortable
in his return to the big losers here is
james mccann
into that modified wind up the 2-2 pitch
james to drive to left field
that's well hit way back there look out
flow
james mccann goes deep and it's three to
one
two starts two home runs for james
mccann and whatever he found last year
he has brought with him through the
winner and he's using it this year
ford home run replay he gets a curveball
very good extension
zach collins the right-hander lets it
fly swung on
foul tip hung on two by sandy leone that
is strike three
one gone top half of the fourth here's
james mccann
and the o2 swing and a miss hey
struck him out and there are two down
back-to-back case for adam pleco
two outs in the fourth 3-1 indians and
here is luis robert
[Applause]
swing and a miss strike three pletco
strikes out
the side in the fourth and we will head
to the bottom of the inning carlos
santana will lead things off for the try
bottom half of the fourth inning no
balls and two strikes on santana and
rodon just runs right through carlos
santana romeo reyes
a strikeout victim his first time up
[Applause]
and john miel reyes draws a walk
domingo did he hold up he did and back
to back walks issued by rodon
here in the fourth inning and now
two on with one out swing and a miss
chase that one in the dirt and comes up
empty
sandy leone fly to right only time up
i think they'd like to see him go five
but once again he took a misstep
fell off the mound sandy leone looking
around
he wants to see if carlos is okay after
this is the second time that he's kind
of stumbled off the mound
taking a missed step just took his
pullover off
in the bullpen carlos is asking for
somebody to come out and uh
till the field that's the first one from
earlier
looked like he just turned the right
foot
here's the last one
yeah it didn't land correctly and he
turned the ankle
here's the 3-0 pitch fastball upstairs
ball four
he has walked the bases loaded here in
the fourth inning
pulls rodon after three and two thirds
sea shacks coming in
bases loaded big spot early two down
when we come back
oscar mercado trying to expand the
indians lead here in the fourth
oh boy that's a line drive smash into
left field they're gonna wave home
santana reyes scores santana scores as
well
and it's a two out two run single for
oscar mercado
and the indians lead is now five 5-1 so
pletco working to a brave
jose center field mercado back still
going at the track and the wall it's
gone
that ball carries up and out of the
sock's second home run
of game two makes it five to two jose
now two for three with that home run
jack collins saga d-h over three tonight
two down a runner on collins drives one
in the air fairly deep left center
mercado back on the track
near the wall he jumps and he made the
catch
what a play by mercado he ran
and leaped at the last moment crashing
into the wall and left
center and robbing zach collins of an
extra base rbi
hit what a play by mercado and the white
sox
had a chance for a big inning snuffed
out by oscar mercado
five to three garcia
here's the payoff bouncer to first
santana
can't come up with it cleanly lift up
what a play to end the ball game
oh yes santana
with a great bare hand flip but how
about cam hill sprinting off the foul
and almost doing a karaoke at the bag to
hold on to it
and the ball game comes to an end as the
indians win it
five to three and cam hill has a save
in just his second big league appearance
it's almost like santana didn't even
look he was just going to backhand it
knowing that he didn't have any time but
hill was there
give him credit boy he beat the guy to
the bag he was able to find the bag put
his foot on it
make the play what a way to end the game
that was
a great day of baseball for the
cleveland today that's for sure